gonna take a look at the better whoa 67%
battery life are you joking me hey guys
this is Vadim with Mac's tech and today
we're gonna be playing pub G and asphalt
9 on both the pixel 3a XL which comes in
at four hundred and seventy nine dollars
and it's packing the same processor and
graphics as the regular pixel 3a and
we're going to compare it to the pixel
three the higher-end model that's eight
hundred dollars is packed in the
snapdragon 845 which is the same one
that's in the pixel three XL and
basically we're going to be seeing if
you can still get good gaming
performance on the cheap $479 pixel 3a
XL instead of having to pay a lot more
for the pixel three alright guys here we
are and the pixel 3a excel and first
thing I want to show you we're at a
hundred percent brightness right here in
100% battery life so we're also gonna be
testing the battery life as well I have
no other apps open except for asphalt 9
and so far everything's like a little
bit glitchy like it's like stuttering
and I can tell the graphics quality is
so much worse there's like a lot of I
don't know if it's aliasing going on so
I mean the screen looks really good this
OLED screen is awesome but the graphics
quality is just so much lower than what
I'm used to so far the experience is not
too bad it's definitely not perfect it's
a little stutter II but I think the
target market for this device let's say
it's parents of young teenagers that are
wanting to get their kids a phone at a
cheap price like this for hundreds of
$480 I think this is actually not too
bad all right guys here we are on the
pixel 3 as you guys can see right a
hundred percent battery life and a
hundred percent brightness as well we
only have asphalt nine open so let's get
into it so right away you guys can see
that the screen is a lot smaller on the
pixel 3 obviously and you might be
asking why am i comparing the pixel 3
axl to the smaller pixel 3 well this
shows you guys the difference in the
screen size and we're gonna see if it's
more worth it to jump up to either the
pixel 3a XL or the pixel 3 Excel for a
better gaming experience so one thing I
noticed instantly is that you can't
block the speed
with your hand as you guys can see there
is a bottom facing speaker right here
it's facing you it's not facing the
bottom of the phone so you can't block
it with your own finger like this like
you can on a three Axl so that's
actually really nice with the pixel
three and instantly I'm no longer
getting that stuttery feeling the laggy
feeling that I got with the pixel 3a and
I've got to say the graphics also look
great they look so much better so I
recommend you guys go back and look at
the footage of the pixel 3/8 XL that I
took a little bit earlier and just
compare to compare what it looks like
compare the differences alright guys so
here I am in pub on the three Axl and
I'm on HD graphics because HDR is not
yet available on this device so far the
graphics look not too bad
definitely better than asphalt 9 alright
I just jumped down and I'm not seeing
any drop frames it's actually performing
very well so far alright guys so far
what I've noticed playing pub G is it's
actually really smooth the graphics
don't look too that at all they look
just fine to me much better than asphalt
9 Oh a little bit of drop frames right
there but honestly it's not that big of
a deal I've been playing for around 30
minutes and honestly the phone doesn't
really feel that hot at all I think it's
because of the really efficient
snapdragon 670 processor it's not that
powerful so it's not gonna get that hot
the graphics are ok they're not perfect
they're not as good as something like
the iPhone 10 are for sure but we'll
have to test out a pixel 3 headshot
another headshot I'm also really
impressed with this display it looks
really great and you're getting an
awesome OLED screen for this cheap price
honestly it's such a good deal
got'em is that it alright guys so it's
been an hour since I started playing on
the pixel 3 axl that's after asphalt 9
after pub G and our battery life is
sitting at 84% so that gives you guys a
good idea of how much battery life
you're going to use while playing for
an hour at hundred percent brightness
which usually most people won't so here
we are on the pixel three and this time
we can choose HDR and ultra frame rate
instead of just high like we had on the
3a XL so that's really nice so for
everything's really smooth no drop
frames
nothing like that graphics look
incredible so far oh did I got him I
also really love that the bottom speaker
is facing you so you can't cover it
anyway you hold this phone so that's
really nice and I think it's really
important for games like pub G or you're
trying to hear footsteps all around you
and one thing with the smaller display
is that the UI is actually a little bit
more cramped together so it's a little
bit uncomfortable to use compared to the
XL model boom that wasn't a headshot are
you kidding Arius boom oh man I love
this sniper so it's been about 30
minutes playing on the pixel 3 and I
actually feel the back of the phone
heating up a little bit more than the
pixel 3 8 X L did oh you guys see that
some dropped frames right there so it's
definitely not perfect whoa
gotta I'd say the only hard thing is
that the display is a little bit too
small to be honest so the graphics are
much better on the pixel 3 you can't
doubt that at all the frames per second
as higher feels super smooth it's
definitely better than the pixel 3 axl
but how much better I'll tell you guys
in just a minute during the conclusion
you got him
boom got him as well so it's been an
hour playing on the pixel 3 let's go
ahead cut this short I'm gonna take a
look at the battle whoa
67% battery life are you joking me
playing an hour at maximum
brightness which most people won't do
alright guys so after playing one hour
on each phone here are my conclusions
first of all the battery life difference
is shocking so after playing an hour on
the pixel 3a Excel we ended up with 86%
battery life which is amazing but on the
pixel 3 we ended up with 67% battery
life that's 33% battery life used up in
only an hour now I know you guys are
gonna say that the pixel 3a Excel has a
larger battery and it does it's actually
27% larger than this guy so if we
accounted for the battery size
difference then this phone should have
only taken up 18% instead of 14% but it
took up 33% so it seems like the more
powerful processor and graphics is
really soaking up that battery life I
actually checked the maximum brightness
difference and both of them are actually
really even in there both at the same
resolution as well so it's really
interesting that the pixel 3 is using so
much more battery life I'm extremely
impressed with a pixel 3a Excel it
didn't quite play at the best graphics
settings or the best frame rate like the
pixel 3 but it was a smooth experience
and if you're paying only 479 dollars or
400 for the pixel 3a it's hard to
believe that you can play pub G pretty
well on this cheap phone and guys if
you're gonna be playing games on one of
these phones I definitely recommend
buying the Excel version whether it's a
3a Excel or the 3 Excel definitely buy
the excel for gaming because that extra
screen real estate is so much more
useful thank you guys for watching I
hope you guys enjoy this game in
comparison if you haven't already
subscribed hit that button above and
make sure to check out those 2 other
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]